Just before we get started,
I do want to mentioned another channel that I host called mega projects,
mega projects. This is a channel all about mega projects,
or I take a deep look at incredible buildings, project structures,
and more whether it's the world's most impressive skyscrapers,
the international space station,
or to enable sarcophagus a covered or new videos come out a couple of times a
week on mega projects. So if you think it could be for you,
please do head on over and subscribe.
There is a link below and let's get into it.
The whole fabric of America is bloody to its very core and there's no quicker
way to find out someone shares your blood loss than when the subject of serial
killers comes up. Think about the recent Rene Psalms of true crime shows.
Look at what some of the top rated podcasts are.
People can't get enough murder in their recreational unwinding time.
It's a way of living vicariously and maybe it's healthy overall,
but it's more than a little dark serial killers and their tales of adventure.
That captivated the public really seemed to hit a stride in the 1960s and
thereafter,
the Zodiac killer son of Sam ed Dean and John Wayne Gacy kept people glued to
their newspapers and news broadcasts to see what awful mesmerizing things
they had done. The cities and towns where these killers operated,
stayed gripped in fear during the unpredictable than sporadic reigns of terror.
And so that was just as true in the upstate New York town of Rochester in the
early 1970s there between 1971 and 1973,
someone was kidnapping children and murdering them.
But that's just the beginning of the weirdness surrounding these cases here
today, we take a look at the alphabet murders.
Mouse ran up.
In the middle of afternoon of November, the 16th, 1971.
Ten-year-old Carmen colon was running errands before returning back to our home
in Rochester,
she made a stop at a pharmacy to pick up a prescription for our grandmother.
And while being informed that the medication was not yet ready to be picked up,
became noticeably distracted and upset.
She told the owner of the pharmacy that she had to go and she got into a car
parked nearby three hours later.
She was reported missing to the Rochester police department in those few hours
between her leaving the pharmacy and to becoming an official missing person.
She was observed to local interstate half naked and flailing her arms for help.
A vehicle identified as a dark Ford Pinza was backing up forensically and trying
to run her down and eventually an individual overpowered her and throw it back
in the car. About 30 motorists on the highway,
witnessed the acts though not one soul attempted to intervene in the apparent
abduction.
None of the drivers who saw what happens even thought to call it in until three
days later. Unfortunately by that time it was too late on November.
The 18th two teenagers came across the body of common Guerlain,
nearly 12 miles from where she was seen struggling on the,
some of our clothing was in fact found near that very highway.
She had been raped.
Her skull had been fractured and she had been strangled to death.
Local newspapers soon offered up a meager award for whoever could offer
information leading to an arrest and some billboards. What nature were erected,
asking for clues the potential suspects that would crop up after the first
murder only added more perplexing questions to the case
Was common Colin's uncle. And after our parents split up,
he became even closer to Carmen and her mother,
when she would take a usual walks to the pharmacy,
she was usually accompanied by her grandfather, Felix,
but on the day of the disappearance,
she somehow persuaded him to let her travel alone.
This was the day that she got into a strange car. Later on the highway,
she was fleeing from what was presumably the same car,
a dark Ford Pinto hatchback just before common Conan went missing.
Her uncle Miguel took possession of a car that eerily matched the car from the
highway incidents. When the authorities learned of this,
they went to Miguel's home to search the vehicle. During the investigation,
they took note of the car. Having recently been profusely cleaned,
especially the trunk,
which had been gone over in detail with a rather strong cleaning products. Now,
if you've paid attention to anyone's car trunk ever you'll know that this is a
pretty rare occurrence. Investigators asked the dealership.
If that was a common practice,
since it was a relatively new purchase on Miguel's behalf,
the dealer stated that they have not conducted such a cleaning, more creepily.
A doll of Carmen was found in the car,
which he explains off by saying he was a family member and that it wasn't very
strange at all, but it was strange. However,
it was Miguel's sudden panic two days after Common's death,
in which she allegedly told a friends that he had to flee the country because he
had done something wrong in Rochester.
And indeed he did take off for Puerto Rico very soon after.
And this isn't the last year here about Miguel colon in this video.
Hmm.
Early April afternoon in 1972, more than a year after common Colin's murder,
11 year old Wando Alco it's was heading home after an errands,
much like Carmen had been in a hometown of Rochester, just like Carmen.
She was getting groceries and headed back down the road towards the house.
It was 5:15 PM. Joyce Wanda's mother reported her missing it around 8:00 PM.
A slew of detectives canvassed an enormous area of land near our home.
They scarred the area around the grocery store.
They knew she had been out before a disappearance and they searched near the
local river where they knew she would sometimes play rescue teams out.
A few straggling reports of wander grocery bags in hand resting against the
fence to keep herself from dropping the bags.
As a dark Brown Vic had approached at a 10:00 AM.
The next morning a policeman found her body at the base of a Hill.
It had been apparently thrown from a moving car and rolled down to the ground
below. She had been sexually assaulted and choked to death, much like common.
The previous yet she had fought her attacker,
which was clear from the defensive wounds. Oddly,
she had a noticeable amount of white hair on her body,
even though no family owned such animals during the autopsy,
custard was discovered around her contents,
something a family swore she would not have eaten at home or school.
So it was her killer feeding.
Her hotlines were set up much larger rewards of $10,000 were offered.
And tips rolled in from the public one tip came from someone who said they saw
one to speaking with the driver of that Brown car from the passenger side window
just before she went missing.
Another tip said they saw a man forcing a girl matching wanders,
looks into a light colored Dodge dot type automobile.
Flyers were plastered all over the surrounding neighborhoods in the hopes that
any shred of evidence would point investigators in the right direction.
The already apparent surface similarities between common and wonders cases were
almost immediately dismissed by the local police departments. More suspects,
more tips, and even more questions.
Michelle.
Was returning home from school on November the 26th, 1973,
just about seven months after the murder of Wando alphabets.
The 11 year old stopped as a Rochester department store on the way back
attempting to fetch a purse. A mother had left there earlier, her uncle pasta,
some points offering to give her a ride, but Michelle opted to go it alone.
Witnesses reported that soon after she was seen entering a tan or beige vehicle,
this was not her uncle's car.
Her mother reported her missing that evening around 4:30 PM.
A girl who matched Menzes his features were seen eating at a fast food
restaurant with a man described as a Caucasian between the ages of 25 and 35 and
roughly six feet tall or 165 pounds,
a person traveling down a nearby road around 5:30 PM.
That days that they saw the same beige or tan colored vehicle as earlier in the
afternoon. But with a flat tire,
the motorist also apparently saw a girl that looked very much like Michelle and
noticed she was in a fair amount of distress.
She was being held by the wrist by the driver outside of the car.
And when the approaching witness tried to stop and check on the girl,
he was matched with a glare by the suspect.
The kidnapper tried to hide the girl behind him and also attempted to keep his
license plate out of sight.
He puts off a menacing enough vibe that the would be helper drove off.
Two days later on November, the 28th, Michelle mans,
his body was found in a ditch roughly 50 miles from our home,
just like the first two victims she had been sexually assaulted and then
strangled with some kind of rope or cord. And just like one, two alphabets.
She had numerous strands of white cat hair on her.
Some small samples of prints and seamen were able to be recovered.
And upon autopsy,
her stomach contents included traces of hamburger backing up the story of her
lost being seen at a fast food restaurant,
a composite sketch of the man who was seen with her was circulated,
but like most of the tiny nuggets of possible leads that crept up through the
case, real concrete information was not to be had.
[Inaudible].
So why were these dubbed the alphabet murders? Well,
you may have noticed that all three victims first and last names that started
with the same letter as time has gone on experts.
Think the likelihood that this was intentional is very low,
but even if the killer had chosen his victims on this basis,
that's not even the strangest of the similarities in the crimes.
There's the final resting place of each body.
All three children were from Rochester, but when their bodies were discovered,
it was in a different town and each town corresponded to their names.
Carmen Caroline's body was found in the town of Churchville Orlando.
Accurate's we're seven miles away from Rochester in the town of Webster.
And Michelle Monza was found in Mason.
While you could argue that the names were coincidences,
it's hard to argue that the killer didn't somehow plan to dump each victim in a
place that matched their name lettering.
There's also the obvious facts that each of the victims was a pre-teen girl.
They all disappeared during rainy days.
We're a short height and we're all seen as loner types,
without many close friends. The positioning of each body when they were found,
seemed to point to them all being stoned from a vehicle.
Each girl was brought up in a poor Catholic family and had a history with being
bullied and having issues with academic performance in school,
which gave investigators some inkling that the murderer may have had a
background in social services and thus had access to knowing these very specific
details about the girls.
[Inaudible].
As long as we mentioned spirited away to Puerto Rico for short days after his
niece was killed in March of 1972,
investigators made their way down there to begin asking him questions about her
disappearance and murder,
or the fact that he had a car that resembled the one scene during the time of
commons kidnapping and the suspicious extent to which the vehicle had been
cleaned, gave them plenty of suspicion. However, down in Puerto Rico,
newspapers caught wind of the authorities desire to interview him and published
articles that Miguel saw causing him to fleet.
He did return later in March and was extradited back to New York state during
questioning Miguel was not able to provide a sufficient excuse for where he was
during commons disappearance and has no other people who could back him up
regarding his location that day, despite strong suspicion,
but they have their guy in the end.
There was no physical evidence that could definitively link him or his car to
the crimes. In 1991, 20 years after his niece was killed.
Miguel took his own life after being involved in a dispute at home where he shot
his brother and his wife,
the good Samaritan who tried to approach the individual who had captured
Michelle mains, uh, was a bit of help.
Even though the kidnapper tried to block him from seeing his license plate,
that person was able to read off a partial plate to the authorities,
as luck would have it.
He ran across the same car several days later and was able to provide the full
license plate number.
This led police to a man living with this family and lawns, New York,
just over 40 miles from Rochester. This new suspect had a beige colored.
So down a strong resemblance to witness sketches and had been in trouble with
the law for petty crimes required to while it's alimony to the police was that
he had been out looking for work that entire date upon further investigation and
perusing phone records. It seems that his alibi was at site,
even passed a polygraph. The suspect never had his name released.
And even though he might've been the closest to police got to a real lead and
other lbs out Dennis demine was another potential lead in the alphabet murders,
a local firefighter in the Rochester area, too many.
It was also known as the garage rapist and had raped at least 14 females between
the years of 1971 and 1973, which are the years that the alphabet mergers,
Curt so many owns a beige colored car,
which was the color of vehicle that had been seen at more than one of the
abductions.
He also resided on the street very close to the area where witnesses last
reported.
Seeing Michelle Menza Menza was thought to be the last victim of the alphabet
murders. But five weeks after a death,
Dennis Domini tried to pull a gun on a teenage girl with the intent of
abducting, her. She started screaming, which led him to flee the scene,
but he obviously didn't learn his lesson and try it again. Soon off to get up.
Another girl police were made aware and started off to him to many was not going
to be captured alive. And so he shot himself in the head years later,
forensic studies were conducted with 10 minis, zoomed corpse.
They compared to DNA from his body to semen samples that were saved from Wando.
Acquits nothing matched. Unfortunately,
no evidence was available from Michel means his body,
the one victim they had most closely tied to his car. However,
had all sorts of white cat air on the surfaces within and as we know why scatter
was found on two of the alphabet victims,
then this Kenneth Yankee who drew police interest because he lived in works near
the first two murder locations. He held jobs as an ice cream man,
a security guard and an ambulance driver,
which made investigators think he wore many uniforms that would make children
approach him and trust him.
He too had a car that matched the description passed around as being near the
scenes of the alphabet abductions. Bianca moved to California in 1976,
three years after the last killing,
he and his cousin became serial killers on the West coast,
known as the hillside strangler between 1977 and 1978.
They murdered 10 females between the ages of 12 and 28 though.
Bianca strongly denies having anything to do with the alphabet murders. Yes.
Another subject was Joseph NASA who did his own series of killings in
California, between 1977 and 1994.
His victims were mostly believed to be prostitutes.
But one interesting detail that came up was that all the females he killed first
and last names that began with the same letter, just like the alphabet murders.
NASA was also a Rochester, New York native and lived there in the early 1970s.
In fact, he often traveled back and forth between New York and California,
and this wasn't lost on investigators.
The same samples they tested from wonder Wacker what's his body against Dennis
to many were tested against naysayers DNA and they did not match NASA was
convicted of his own California alphabet murders, however,
and was sentenced to death in 2013,
when police searched his house more thoroughly,
they found an absolutely insane journal.
The way NASA kept the details of his murder.
Obviously the alphabet murders remain unsolved to this day.
This all pieces of evidence have pointed to many potential suspects,
but none of it has been indisputable enough to land a conviction.
It's not even truly known. If all three murders are definitely connected.
Tips rolled in from the public and new suspects had a brief light shined on
them, but then something wouldn't connect,
a polygraph would parcel and alibi would line up.
Did Joseph Nissa merely move to California and continue killing their retaining
the alphabet method? Was it someone else entirely?
And they just moved somewhere else and killed that.
Did they feel like the law was closing in after the third merger and they
somehow quelled the urge to kill again?
There aren't so many questions and zero sense of closure for the families.
Even the experts have a hard time drawing conclusions.
One such expert was Robert wrestler who actually came up with the term serial
killer and do spent decades profiling them and trying to get inside their heads.
Wrestler worked at the FBI and the behavioral sciences units where he got to
examine the actions and thoughts of some of the most horrid people that ever
lived.
Wrestler actually did not believe that the same person conducted all three
killings. When you draw profiles of the killers,
he believed that commons killing shows a much higher level of anger and
aggression.
She also had not received food before a death like the other two girls seemingly
did finally the killer choked out with his hands,
whereas wander and Michelle had ligatures used on them.
The experts also seem to believe that the matching first and last initials of
each victim was purely coincidence.
They believed that the level of thought required organizational skill,
that the killer simply did not have the murders,
the brutal dumping of the bodies,
and even the kidnappings themselves at no methodical orchestration to them.
Is it possible that the killers trial run with common,
didn't go according to plan and that he got better at his work with the next
two. Of course, we just can't say
The New York state police city of Rochester police and two neighboring County
departments all still have open cases for the girls who were killed the
departments still work closely together and meet to discuss new details.
When they come up new technology being much more advanced than what was
available in the 1970s,
they are now able to test genetics and swab for DNA to create new suspects or
eliminate past ones.
Databases are available to instantly access information from decades ago,
the original detectives meet with the new guard to pick each other's brains and
share leads.
They all share the same sense of wanting to honor the memories of the girls and
help the families close a door. That's been maddeningly left open for so long.
Carmen colon one, two acrobats,
and Michelle May now all share the same cemetery in Rochester was that final
resting place. So I'm not going to ask whether you enjoyed that video,
but I do hope you found it interesting. At least if you did,
please do hit that like button below. Don't forget to subscribe as always.
Thank you for watching.
[Inaudible].